[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain a japanese mystery thriller film
called honor student spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
the story starts in ichikawa high school
in a small japanese town the senior
students are in the classroom receiving
their recent test results one of the
students is miyamoto asuka a friendly
but academically dumb student even
though the test was the easiest one so
far she doesn't get any answers right
and scores a zero her boyfriend yoshida
looks at the brighter side stating that
zero is asuka's lucky number they are
scolded by the teacher who knows if
asuka doesn't start studying her future
is bleak then it is time for another
history test that asuka dreads the first
question asks her to name a monument
that is famous for granting wishes when
offered a coin she doesn't know the
answer but instead of leaving the space
blank she writes the name of a random
place called gachimo just when she puts
the name down on the paper bright light
can be seen outside the window somewhere
in the city a strange path of jungle
forms on its own the following day she
and yoshida are on their way to school
when they come across a path they do not
remember it being there prior to today
which makes them curious letting
curiosity get the best of them the
couple decides to explore it after a
minute's walk they find a shrine whose
name they cannot pronounce asuka throws
a coin and wishes to get a hundred on
his next test the two then return to
school without thinking much of the
exploration they get the result of the
previous test and asuka scores 5 out of
100 she huffs at herself for believing
in the shrine's power that day the class
has yet another quiz about world
politics the first question asks them
the name of the current japanese prime
minister asuka doesn't have a clue but
instead of leaving the paper blank she
writes yoshida's name on it she doesn't
know the answers to any of the questions
after that so instead she takes a nap
after school asuka and yoshida go to her
house to hang out as soon as they walk
in they hear the noise of her parents
arguing her father is a salesman who is
about to be laid off while her mother
has an affair with a younger man asuka
asks yoshida to ignore them and brings
him to her room on the way he notices
empty plates and bowls outside a door it
turns out that asuka has a twin brother
named kesake he used to be the best in
his studies ever since elementary school
he never scored anything less than a
full score on every test but that is
until one day when he failed the high
school entrance exam since he was known
as the best scorer the failure was very
hard on him ever since then he has
locked himself away in his room he
doesn't talk to anyone and is always on
the computer playing games my kind of
guy asuka sulks after talking about her
brother to make her feel better yoshida
goes to the supermarket to get them
something to eat somewhere else their
teacher is grading the test papers
suddenly the shrine starts glowing and
so do the teacher's glasses a while
later asuka calls yoshida and asks him
what is taking so long yoshida claims
that he is terribly busy and won't be
able to hang out today right after the
call she gets a text from her classmate
saying that yoshida is in huge trouble
it turns out that he has been selected
as the prime minister of japan the
interviews of him posing for the camera
as the prime minister are going viral on
social media the next day asuka goes to
school still confused about how her
boyfriend who went to the grocery store
turned into the prime minister well
people have been elected for less
several other news about the presidents
of different countries going missing is
also going around the school the teacher
arrives with the graded papers and hands
asuka hers with a big smile on his face
surprisingly enough she got full marks
on the test even though she left most of
it empty on taking a closer look she
realizes that yoshida became the prime
minister because she wrote so on the
test similarly the presidents of other
countries are going missing because she
left all the other questions blank the
shrine has granted her the wish but in a
different way than she would have
thought now the world will change
according to her answers for her to get
the full marks to redeem her mistake she
googles all the right answers and writes
them down on the test paper fortunately
enough the plan works and yoshida is
fired on his first day at work the
presidents from around the world are
also found instantly and everything goes
back to normal it is then time for the
next test this time asuka is not nervous
because nothing much can be changed if
she answers wrong on a math test after
school yoshida meets asuka again and
tells her how he was fired asuka calms
him down before telling him the truth
about her strange power yoshida doesn't
believe her and asks her to write
something to prove it but before she can
a tower in the middle of the town starts
wiggling this is because of a mistake
she made on the math test the couple
immediately runs to the teacher's room
and corrects the mistake finally
bringing the tower to its original form
even the experts on tv cannot explain
what caused the building to wiggle while
returning home asuka and yoshida go to
the place where the shrine was earlier
but it has completely vanished by now
since they do not remember the name they
have no way to look for it again now the
only way to save the world is for asuka
to study hard and get all the questions
right determined to do her best she sits
down to study that night but falls
asleep a few minutes later in the
following scene asuka and yoshida are
outside the teacher's room patiently
waiting for him to grade the recent test
papers as expected asuka gets full marks
but she hopes she doesn't make a
significant change to the world on
returning home her father greets her
excitedly having made the biggest sale
of his career asuka unknowingly wrote
that tap water is the most valuable
source of energy in the last test this
made people buy more water purifiers and
in turn made her father a lot of money
she panics for a second but after seeing
her father happy she decides to keep the
world as it is for now later that day
the news reports a bunch of riots
happening around the world for water
when things get out of hand asuka
quickly corrects the answer sheet and
changes the world back to normal
suddenly she gets an idea to solve her
parents marital problems using the power
that she has in the next test she has
asked the name of the astronaut who is
about to go on a long trip to space she
writes the name of her mother's
boyfriend and sends him to space the
next day because of this he breaks up
with her mother she starts focusing on
her family and her husband after his
departure
asuka's life could not get any better
now the only person she has to help is
her twin brother quesake in the next
test she writes that her brother would
come out and wish everyone good morning
that's a weird answer what was the
question the plan doesn't work as she
had thought though because instead of
kasikay coming out their father barges
into his room and forces him to come
outside this causes a huge argument in
the family it is revealed that her
father has again been threatened to be
laid off and her mother has started
texting other men asuka finally
registers that solving her problems with
the power is only temporary she starts
making an actual effort to talk to her
brother since he is still an academic
genius she sits outside his door and
studies out loud every day she makes
several mistakes that bother casakay but
he doesn't correct her for a few days
then one day she tries skipping a math
problem because it is too difficult
kasakay talks for the first time and
teaches her how to solve it because of
her brother's guidance asuka starts
studying harder even though he only
talks to her through a closed door
eventually her father starts reading
books for salesmen and puts extra effort
into his work as well her mother also
deletes all of her lovers numbers from
her phone and focuses on her family
why'd she do that who knows a week later
asuka scores the full marks on a test
without anyone's help she runs to kasake
with the good news but he refuses to
open the door even then the following
morning asuka and her parents are at a
dining table enjoying a meal to their
surprise kasikay comes downstairs and
greets them he also apologizes to his
father for giving up and promises to do
better from now on one day on their way
to school asuka and yoshida find the
first test paper inside asuka's bag she
had torn it because she scored only five
out of a hundred she joins the pieces
together which suddenly forms the
passageway to the shrine only then does
she notice that she had written about a
wish granting shrine named gauchimo as
the very first answer the shrine must
have manifested because of it the couple
quickly goes to the shrine and begs to
reverse the wish and change the world
back to normal they wait for something
to happen and are disappointed when
nothing changes in school the teacher
takes yet another test this time about
world geography and population suddenly
asuka remembers that the shrine only
granted her wish because she offered a
coin this means to reverse the wish she
will have to take the coin back she
quickly completes the test and rushes to
retrieve it however the coin is inside a
locked chest she uses a stick to try to
get it out and is almost successful
somewhere else kasich and his parents
are chatting about his future he is
happy to have finally gotten over his
hiatus and is excited for his life ahead
his mother is also sorry to have
troubled her husband so much the family
finally solves their differences in one
sitting simultaneously we see asuka's
teacher grading the most recent test he
gets to asuka's paper and she scores a
hundred as usual at the same time she
accidentally drops the coin back into
the chest suddenly the coin shines a
bright light on her seconds later no one
is in front of the shrine in fact the
entire city country and the world is
empty as if every human being vanished
out of the blue in the last scene we see
that asuka missed the final question in
the recent test the question asks what
the current world population is since
asuka left it blank humans stop existing
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching